welcome my name is Bill Alfred I'm the
Henry Stimson professor of law and
director of east asian legal studies and
it's my pleasure to welcome you today
before we commence I want to mention
that we are allowing c-span to tape this
event we're sorry we weren't able to
apprise people of this in advance there
will be a microphone passed around
during the question period so please
wait for that to come we do this in the
spirit of helping mr. buruma publicizes
very important book we are honored to
have ian buruma here he is someone who
does not fit into established categories
well he is variously described as an
accomplished journalist a commentator on
contemporary Asia a prominent social
critic but none of these labels begin to
do justice to him he really is a true
public intellectual in the best sense of
the word an increasingly rare phenomenon
I might add he's somebody who blends a
vast and eclectic learning about the
whole world with a wonderfully
imaginative and probing intellect a
powerful but occasionally puckish
writing style and a consistent strong
conscience as he tries to make some
sense with courage and insight of this
very messy the world of ours and in
particular as New York Times put it
quote the cultural political world known
as Asia any close quote now in a recent
interview responded to a question about
his ideal reader by saying that quote he
or she would have to be curious
reasonably well-informed but not a
specialist in Asian affairs close quote
this is indeed true but I can adjust
that even for those of us who do
specialize in Asian affairs his work is
enormously valuable and stimulating I
would be hard put to think of anybody
writing in the West through whose eyes
one might draw a fuller richer more
prescient appreciation of the
political and moral challenges that
confront Asia and one can see this
throughout the span of his work which is
is just extraordinarily impressive in
its breath writing about such varied
topics as the legacy of World War two
for Japan the films of sajid ray
wonderful films the Singaporean state
the Hong Kong transition the road to
democracy shin in Taiwan and of course
as we shall hear today of a PRC ian
buruma was born approximately 50 years
ago in the netherlands to dutch and
british parents and he studied chinese
literature in history at the University
of Leiden from which many of our faculty
members elsewhere at Harvard seem to
have come and later did his graduate
work in Japanese cinema at nihon
university after a stint as a
documentary filmmaker and photographer
in Tokyo he became cultural editor of
far eastern economic review I might say
that the time as a filmmaker and
photographer seems well spent as you
read his prose which is lush and
pictorial and really helps bring distant
places and people alive he's also been
the foreign editor at The Spectator he's
had distinguished fellowships at the
business shaft college in Berlin at the
Woodrow Wilson Center in Washington and
at Oxford and he's managed throughout
this time to publish a number again of
important and highly readable books
including behind the mask God's dust
about Southeast Asia the wages of guilt
looking at the different German and
Japanese reactions to the legacy of
World War two the missionary and the
libertine love and war in east and west
which the Atlantic extolled for its area
dition and elegance and of course the
book about which he'll be speaking today
bad elements a title meant ironically in
addition he writes with great regularity
for the New York Review of Books the new
york times magazine The Guardian and
many other publications indeed in the
Guardian in the last three months he has
had a fascinating series of columns many
of which deal with the reactions to
September 11th so he
with great great pleasure that we
welcome in buruma thank you very much
with these very kind words which are
always slightly embarrassing to hear
it's a bit like the way one would like
to fantasize and attending one's own
funeral I suppose as you can imagine
it's a slightly uphill struggle going
around telling people to worry about
China these days since China seems like
an oasis of calm and peace in a
exploding world which is not the way it
seemed only six or seven months ago
nonetheless I think it is worth still
worrying about China and even though
perhaps not in the short term as much as
it is worth worrying about the Middle
East but the the key word that is used
about China by commentators diplomats
businessmen everybody who is involved in
China tends to be stability people use
the word stability about China more
often than they seem to about any other
country and I think there are various
reasons for this the use of the word
stability usually goes together not
always but usually goes together with a
kind of grudging sometimes not so
grudging defense of strong paternalistic
authoritarian rule in order to guarantee
such stability as though such rule is
the only natural kind of government for
the Chinese people given their
traditions in their history and so on
and at any other any alternative way of
governing China would lead to chaos and
mayhem in the streets and so on now I
think there are various reasons for that
kind of apologetics and support of the
status quo of China being ruled by a
paternalist authoritarian party and one
of them is practical the other perhaps
has a little bit more to do with
traditional China the practical one I
can illustrate by an anecdote that I
that came to me
happened to me this summer when I was on
the way to Beijing enough and then from
Beijing to Moscow where I'd never been
before in order to write an article and
somebody advise me in Britain to go and
see an academic and Cambridge who knew
he was a specialist in Chinese economics
but also knew a lot knows a lot about
the Soviet Union and he would be the
perfect person to consult and to do my
homework and I did meet him in London
and he had a slightly oddly
old-fashioned demeanor he seemed like an
old Trotskyite with a lot of unruly hair
and a black t-shirt which hadn't seen
the inside of a washing machine and to
recently and a rather disconcerting way
of flicking from a rather grim and
pained expression to a nervous giggle
which I remember from former Stasi
agents in Berlin they tend to have that
too and in any case we got talking and
very quickly he got very overexcited and
he started saying it's absolutely
imperative that the Communist Party in
China keeps absolute control of China
otherwise those Democrats will do what
those Democrats did in Russia and
they'll wreck the country and if it were
up to me I would throw every dissident
and Falun Gong believer in to jail the
old language for a Cambridge academic we
became frosty as it was soon clear that
our view is diverged before we parted I
asked him when the last time he was that
he'd been to China and he said through
gritted teeth a month ago and he said he
went to China once a month which is even
order for a Cambridge England academic
since they don't get paid the kind of
salary that allows one to travel to
China once a month so in a mood of some
slight mischief I decided to check him
up a check up his background which is
very easily done these days you type his
name into Google and up he comes and I
it turned out that as I had expected he
was indeed an advisor to such and such a
committee of the people's for the
government of the People's Republic of
China but also and this is the
interesting point of the coca-cola
company in atlanta georgia and here we
have a confluence of interests that
didn't exist in india in the old Soviet
Union the the combination of a country
that is ruled by a Leninist party even
though it only pays lip service to
marxist Dogma but it is still a Leninist
party-led government where there's also
a huge amount of money to be laid and
there is a confluence I think of
interests of business interests of those
such as I think this Cambridge academic
who take have always taken the view
China right or wrong and those are the
basically an authoritarian bent now the
other reason why I think people often
intend to argue the China needs sort of
a paternalistic authoritarian government
is perhaps a more traditional one and
the word there's perhaps not stability
but harmony which goes back more to a
Confucian tradition and I think that one
of the great hindrances and barriers to
a democratic transformation in China is
a rather traditional idea where church
and state have not quite separated where
politics is more than governing secular
institutions but politics is bound up
with a system of ethics spiritual life
and so on and in course in the old
imperial days the Emperor was the
mediator between heaven and earth he was
a pope of a kind as well as a monarch
and although the Communist Party have
done their best to destroy the old high
civilization of China a lot of that
thinking got transferred into the
Communist period where the Communist
Party reset itself or claimed
justification for its rule by claiming
to create a new man a new China a new
morality and so on it was not just about
politics it was about behavior and even
spiritual life of a kind in the sense
that the worship of Mao and maoism had a
great many religious trappings which
went way beyond what one normally would
regard as secular politics
and by the same token I think those who
oppose the government's in China and
this also goes back to the pre communist
days are quickly denounced as people who
are disturbing harmony and are therefore
anti-chinese anti-chinese in the sense
that China represents a sort of model
cosmic model of harmony which in which
there's no real place for those who were
challenged it because they can then very
quickly be accused of being against
Chinese culture or against China or
indeed anti-chinese as they're often
described these days but the same
dissidents and rebels who challenge the
government of the day often also see
themselves as saviors of China and see
their role as more than people who are
simply challenging secular institutions
but their role is also to overturn a
kind of moral order and introduce a new
moral order which you can claim greater
moral purity or a different morality or
whatever but in any case it the project
they're engaged in is not quite
separated from a church of a kind and
either now the reason that in my book I
decided to write not just about the
People's Republic of China but about
Taiwan and Hong Kong and Singapore and
the exiles abroad as well in other words
that I wanted to describe the Chinese
speaking world rather than just the PRC
was precisely to challenge this mythical
idea of one China where harmony has to
rule and I wanted to show that people
who come from the same Chinese tradition
linguistic tradition cultural tradition
given different historical circumstances
can go into completely different
political directions and Taiwan not
enough celebrated in my view and has now
stat has demonstrated that there is
absolutely no cultural reason why
Chinese should not be able to handle
democracy and it's and institutions are
guaranteed freedom of speech and so on
and it is absolutely not true that that
once Chinese people can live with such
institutions that there is chaos and
disorder in the land and that they're at
each other's throats and I think the
last election last week gives one great
hope that even in times of economic
crisis which the opposition did its best
to blame on the current government in
power the DPP in in Taiwan that
nonetheless the DPP won so many votes
and I think this shows that the Chinese
like everybody else can live in an
orderly fashion with political freedom
but as I said it was the reason that
that I dealt with the Chinese speaking
world rather than China was precisely to
demonstrate that and the question that
haunted me while I was researching the
book and traveling to Taiwan on various
occasions sometimes during elections and
sometimes not was what was it that
enabled the Taiwanese dissidents to
succeed where other Chinese Democratic
dissidents so far have not of course in
Hong Kong if they'd had the chance they
would have succeeded too but why did
they manage that transition in Taiwan
now there are many reasons of course one
of them is the role of the United States
and in the 1960s leftists like the snare
at the idea of the u.s. client States
sometimes rightly so but in the other
hand it's also true that the only
countries in Asia which have made it in
the last 20 years which has made a
successful transition from dictatorship
to democracy have been precisely those
us client States and the reason is
obvious that when the strongmen had
conceded to elections and then tried to
relate to the back off the US had the
clout to make them hold to their promise
which is not something they can do in
the PRC but I also think the success of
the dissidents in Taiwan
has to do with that cosmic idea of
Chinese politics of saving China on the
one hand or preserving harmony and
therefore legitimacy on the other and
the reason I say this that the
dissidents of the 60s 70s and 80s in
tile at Taiwan where of course mostly
the so-called native Taiwanese people
whose ancestors came to Taiwan three
hundred years ago as in contrast to the
so-called mainlanders who came to Taiwan
in the late 1940s with the Guaman dong
the KMT led by general Chiang kai-shek
and the last thing that the native
Taiwanese dissidents wanted was to save
China that was not part of their project
their project was to get the kmt off
their back and break the monopoly on
power of the kmt it was precisely the
KMT that tried to gain legitimacy for
its authoritarian rule in Taiwan and
ultimately if everything had gone
according to plan the whole of China and
they based that idea on that they were
the ones who had preserved and protected
and maintained Chinese culture and I'm
sure some of you perhaps many of you
have been to Taiwan and have been to the
National Museum in Thai Bay which is
full of the rich collection of the Qing
Dynasty Emperor's and it had an overtly
political role to play under the KMT it
was a showcase for the KMT to claim that
they were the ones they were the
guardians of Chinese civilization and
therefore morality and so on and
therefore it was one way to symbolically
justify their rule in Taiwan and their
claim to stand to rule the whole of
China now it was not the role as I said
of the time native Taiwanese dissidents
to somehow take over that role from the
KMT and claim that they whether the
legitimate rulers of China that was not
they not what they were interested in
there Taiwanese nationalism too can be
idealistic
dreamy provincial even tiresome but
nonetheless it never took over the more
secular parts of their democratic
aspirations also I think the fact that
they were liberated from this this old
thing of having to save China was that
they perhaps were more open to ideas
from the non-chinese world the United
States and even from the Japanese
colonial past without feeling that there
were being anti Chinese or betraying
their Chinese heritage or themselves as
Chinese which is also a great help and
one thing that struck me when
interviewing the native Taiwanese
dissidents who had been active in the
70s 60s 80s or no on the whole rather
elderly people and still speak fluent
Japanese and so often spoke Japanese to
me because my Japanese is prompted by me
they would display an extraordinary
japonais filia which is not something
one comes across very often in Asia
certainly not in former Japanese
colonies and they would always point out
that under the Japanese life was harsh
but there was order there was rule of
law there was modernity there was
fairness and so on and under those
mainlanders or sometimes they would even
say when they were speaking Japanese
those Chinese as though they weren't
Chinese there was chaos and disorder and
the mainland Chinese they're the
mainlanders they spit in the streets and
they have no respect for traffic rules
and their uncuff and and so on and so
forth over and over again I would hear
this story and one day I went to see an
old friend of mine from Hong Kong who
now lives in taipei a remarkable figure
called John Shum who was very famous in
Hong Kong as a comedy movie star and he
played a role in 1989 on Tiananmen
Square as one of the main conduits
between the sympathizers in Hong Kong
and the students in Beijing he was the
one who fondled money and tents and
goods and so on to the students he was a
sort of a constant presence presence on
the square in May as a kind of
loser of the Chinese dissidents and
after the the gentleman demonstrations
were crushed he played a further role in
using his showbiz stroke gangster
connections which in Hong Kong were very
close to enable the Chinese student some
of the Chinese students to escape from
China and come to the United States and
what some of them are in this town right
now and i went to see John who now runs
a cable television company in tae BAE
and asked him about this business of the
Taiwanese the native Taiwanese Chinese
being so different from the mainland as
was it true in his opinion he did not
have to think long he said no that's
absolutely untrue the the Taiwanese are
just like the mainland as they spit in
the streets they are there on couth they
have no they disobey the traffic rules
they have no idea of order and so on and
they're just the same they don't really
know what democracy is but of course the
Hong Kong Chinese he said they're very
different we have a sense of fair play
and order and we know how to handle the
democratic institutions and so on and I
said and why is that knowing perfectly
well what he was going to say he said
well because we were under the British
and what this shows I think again is not
a deep fondness amongst the Cantonese
for British colonial rule any more than
there is a true deep fondness amongst
the child Taiwanese for Japanese
colonial rule but it shows on the one
hand a reaction to the overwhelming
force of the modern Chinese state the
other hand I think it also illustrates a
strange I would call it almost a form of
cultural self hatred amongst many
Chinese intellectuals which is that the
flip side I think of a sense of cultural
pride in superiority and bow young an
author on in Taiwan who wrote a book
called the ugly [ __ ] I think is a
very typical example of this it's a kind
of venting of loathing and hatred of
everything that seems to have gone wrong
with China and we Chinese are no good or
dissident I met in the United States we
even talked about the the poison that
isn't
blood of the Han Chinese and the same
people cannot as are also very capable
of lecturing the first foreigner who
comes along about the superiority of
5,000 years of ancient civilization and
so on and it's as though since the 19th
century the humiliation of first
colonialism the opium wars and so on and
then the sense that China has sunk so
low as kind of indented a sense of pride
which then can become a form of
self-loathing but nonetheless that being
so the the Democrats in Hong Kong and in
Taiwan I think have succeeded well in
Hong Kong not yet because they didn't
have the chance but have succeeded
because their aims were largely secular
and they could they were liberated from
the ID from the cultural burden of
having to transform Chinese civilization
indeed they've grasped in Hong Kong to
they've grasped the essence of a
democratic transformation which is the
limit power and not to substitute one
absolute power for another and in Hong
Kong when you talk to the Democrats this
is very clear I mean the the reason that
they wanted democratic reforms was to
preserve the rule of law and the the
individual rights that they did enjoy on
the British colonial rule even though
they never enjoyed democracy of course
but they realized that democracy was the
only way to to preserve it now the sad
thing about Hong Kong is that these
things are now being undermined not by
the government in Beijing who can sit
back and fair and watch things in Hong
Kong feeling fairly relaxed it's being
undermined by the old colonial elite and
sometimes young colonial elite the
tycoon's and so on who used to manage
Hong Kong on the British colonial rule
and now i'm managing hong kong as it
were on the chinese colonial rule and
they have very autocratic instincts and
they had that in the past and it was
tempered somewhat by the fact that the
British colonial government was
accountable to Westminster it's now
perhaps tempered less
and the sad and ironic thing is that
they're claiming precisely the sort of
the cultural regime see that the Hong
Kong Democrats never did when you listen
to governor tong zhi hua not a
connoisseur I might save traditional
Chinese culture I think he probably
knows more about soccer but like many
people who claim cultural reasons for
the legit illegitimate of their their
rule he likes to talk about Chinese
values and Asian values and Confucian
values you know in order to bolster the
legitimacy of his rather autocratic ways
which is a sad and rather dangerous
phenomenon and I'd like to conclude
before opening the floor for a
discussion with the point with which I
began which is this problem of stability
and legitimacy and the chinese communist
party at the moment looks reasonably
stable i would argue that it's much less
stable than it looks and i think this
has to do with this question of
legitimacy under mao at least there was
an orthodoxy however horrible but there
was an orthodoxy which incorporated
morality and and a kind of spiritual
life and so on upon which the Communist
Party could base its claim to legitimacy
that orthodoxy a mishmash of marxist
leninism and Mao Zedong Thought of
course has virtually disappeared and
even the leaders of the Communist Party
now sometimes pay lip service to it but
don't really believe it so there is no
orthodoxy left to give the government
legitimacy and what legitimacy that was
left in the 80s was pretty much crushed
on tenement square once you use tanks to
shoot at your own citizens there's not
much credibility left there are only two
things i would say that i left and both
are potentially dangerous one is the
idea that as long as the communist party
is there there will be prosperity in
china or increased prosperity in china
everybody is going to get rich now this
is a highly vulnerable claim because
everybody's going to get rich in fact
most people are not getting richer at a
particularly fast clip some are and in
times of economic crisis which will
surely come many will get poorer and
indeed this the entry in the WTO may
already sort of show us that this is the
case now what is left if those who feel
left behind dispossessed not listen to
and so on what is left if they have no
way to voice their discontent sin their
interests in a legitimate sense what is
left i think is is mob violence and
again that's already visible there are
bush fires all over china but as long as
there cannot be organized in some form
that can provide a national movement the
chinese government probably will have
very little trouble in putting them out
but it can grow too dangerous
proportions and then I think the
temptation of the government will be to
use that other potent force in China
which is a rather aggressive nationalism
which is based on grievances in past few
milli and and some what mythical often
sense of past humiliations and so on and
I think the government is careful not to
use this too much because it can be
turned against the government itself but
they might use it and even though it's
presented Chinese nationalism is
something that is goes back to some
ancient Chinese culture or a way of
thinking of course it's nothing of the
sort like all forms of late 19th century
I nationalism or not all yeah like all
forms I would save no late nineties him
nationalism it's basically a European
idea and the idea of China is one family
the idea that social cohesion has to be
based on blood and soil and culture and
so on is essentially a late 19th century
German idea which has been incorporated
first in Meiji Japan and then in China
and it's a way to really keep control of
a society which can where people don't
have the right to voice their discontent
and challenge the government in a
legitimate way so the the nationalism
becomes a kind of a tool of control but
it can also if things get out of hand at
home be used to deflect those energies
which could be directed against the
government towards outside enemies and
I'm not suggesting here that china is
going to unleash World War 3 nor am I
even suggesting that they're going to
attack Taiwan certainly not before at
2008 that would be very foolish but it
could at some point lead to
miscalculations which with unforeseen
consequences none of them good and that
is certainly not to be hoped and so I
would conclude on that somber note and
invite you to ask me anything you like
thank you and you can call the official
silence of the tomb
mr. buruma if you had to guess into the
future two or three decades do you think
the PRC is more likely to get bigger
adding Taiwan and maybe some of the
parts of Siberia that Mar said should be
there or do you think it will get
smaller somehow and if the latter
smoothly or roughly well my guess is
neither I don't think that anybody at
the moment and has enough power to stage
a successful secessionist movement so I
don't see much possibility for Tibetan
or Muslim or any other independence
movement nor do I think it's terribly
likely in the near future that Taiwan
will be added to to China because it
could only be done violently and I think
the government in China is unlikely to
to do it the other great danger I think
is that they might miscalculate at some
point and rarely think that it's a
domestic matter how the Taiwanese
problem is solved that the US has no
stomach to put up a fight to defend
Taiwan and forget that actually the u.s.
if they were to intervene which I would
hope they would would not do so simply
for the sake of Taiwan or even for
democratic ideals but they would have to
do it to preserve the security of East
Asia because if they don't then all
kinds of things will happen in Japan and
Korea and so on which which would be
deeply dis table izing now the question
is whether the people in beijing rarely
realize take these things into account
or whether they are which because they
are rather provincial men on the whole
whether they rarely do see it as a
domestic matter now one possible
consequence of 911 is that countries
will be less inclined to think that the
u.s. is simply a flabby decadent country
where people
we'll never fight back if provoked and
this may have made it slightly less
likely that the Chinese will
miscalculate in that particular way hi I
want to ask about the question about
stability I I think here okay you know
legitimacy is certainly a very very
questionable issue here now in China and
I mean particularly regarding those
powerless you know those laid off
workers those peasants know those
migrant workers and and but I I wonder
about what's the what's the kind of
internal mechanism can work out through
the comment party to in a way to promote
its legitimacy whether there is a
possibility or not I mean whether I mean
there are various kind of reforms and
are taking and I mean many Chinese view
all many a westm you can be vastly
different because some view that
although it's questioned but it's not
questioned that far as to me anyway a
question is power and I I mean I i
wonder how would you give it a account
directly yes I I think I understand what
you're saying and I think that they are
attempting to gain legitimacy by
basically trying to imitate the PAP in
Singapore or to some extent even the
liberal democratic party in Japan which
is to create a one-party state which
incorporates almost everybody who
aspires to oar belongs to the elite and
the fact that the the party has now
invited businessmen to become party
members i think is part of that and so
by incorporating the elite by
them off if you want to use a negative
term they hope to defuse any attempts
from the the urban educated more or less
affluent elite to challenge legitimacy
the party in fact in the eyes of that
elite it's in there or they try and make
it into the interest of that elite to
not to challenge it and they may be
successful at that for a while it's the
problem is that it's much more difficult
to do that with as you say with with the
dispossessed with those who are left
behind in in all this and in Singapore
you can make it work for a while because
it's a tiny city-state and it's
relatively easy to raise everybody to us
to a certain level of affluence but in
China that's going to be much more
difficult and I think it's creating a
dangerous situation because if the elite
itself does not give some kind of
leadership in pushing for real
democratic reforms it's basically left
up to the poor and the dispossessed to
voice their discontent in mob violence
because there's no other channel for
them to do so to to to to show their
intro to fight for their interests and
the other aspect of this I think is that
this perhaps is not so much a question
of their legitimacy but that they've
been very successful and clever i think
in defusing dissent and political
opposition by allowing freedoms where it
doesn't directly challenge the
government people's private lives are
clearly much freer than they used to be
and so people have a better life and
even people are able to speak their
minds in private without being
frightened people more frightened in
singapore than they are in china and
i've heard people denounce the Communist
Party in crowded Beijing restaurants
nothing will happen but as soon as you
do anything in an organized fashion
whether its political or cultural or
religious that is not under the control
of the party then you get into deep
trouble and as long as the government
can crush that you won't have the
beginnings of a civil society
and it's going to be very difficult to
have a fundamental reform and I still
have questions like I mean okay you are
talking about those elite class middle
class or get something out of this
reform and those who are dispossessed
and and in fact him deteriorated from
this reform and I mean on the one hand I
think many would argue that government
has not control those kind of violence
whatever proper I mean there are there
every day their various I mean either
you can buy it or you can remain
government may tend to use a minimal
minimal state violence that's enough and
however I mean talking about the civil
society whether it is emerging I I think
he yes I think so I mean I do think it
the chinese civil society are emerging
and are playing a i don't know because
more but i think there is a civil
society are emerging and and so it's
raised the question whether Derek there
can be a kind of smooth transition and
and many Chinese would hope so I'll or
whether as you might see there is a
potential danger and the Samuel but but
it depends what you mean by civil
society if if it's true that is that
individual liberties have been expanded
but civil society does is defined by
organ organizations organized activity
that is not under the control of the
state and as long as that doesn't take
place I don't think you can speak of a
civil society well I mean there are
worse groups like you for example
women's groups who are voicing more outs
actively and they're also i mean
potential peasants organizations who i
mean they are they're still somewhat
like he growing but i am i'm sure they
are their emerging but maybe not to the
extent that it can have organized the
confrontation with the
government perhaps we could thank you go
to another question um I haven't
finished your book yet so if if you
address this in another section I
apologize but it is exam time here at
Harvard so I sort of turn first to the
section on the oversized overseas
mainland Chinese dissident community and
I was glad to see that you were much
more candid about the shortcomings of
that movement and many other writers
tend to be but because of the sort of
the nature of the for lack of a better
term enemy of the China overseas Chinese
dissident movement the communist
government in Beijing and the nature of
the Horrible's that they have
perpetrated against these people who are
now exiled dissidents there's a tendency
to romanticize these men and women who
are involved in this movement however I
almost sort of reading through a thought
it might have been possible to be even
more critical of many of these activists
not all but many of these activists in
terms of wasting golden opportunities to
focus attention on the on the human
rights situation there and wasting a lot
of money in the process yes but old old
overseas dissident communities do this
the Chinese are not unique Joseph Conrad
already described this in the in the
case of Russians in in the early 20th
century that when people who are usually
had strong characters anyway other
otherwise they wouldn't have become
activists when they've suddenly find
themselves displaced in large and
indifferent in unfamiliar cities they
always turn on each other and degenerate
into petty squabbles and so on I don't
think there's anything unusual about
that and you're right i think that
people romanticize the the the student
leaders in the dissidents and so on
about 10 years ago i'm not sure that's
true anymore i think on the contrary
there's been a tendency in the press to
either dismiss them as irrelevant or two
as it is often the case with waging chun
for example to characterize them as sort
of buffoonish
foolish uncompromising chain-smoking
people who are ridiculous but not
important and although you're right that
I didn't try and and gloss over their
problems I never wanted to denounce them
partly because I have great respect for
people who put their and stick their
necks out in very dangerous situations
as many of them did and I'm not told
sure I would do so in under those
circumstances and I think they have to
be respected for that always also
because in the case of somebody like way
for example he is a man of principle and
yes he's uncompromising and and
headstrong and stubborn and so on but he
has a principle and I think that the
main role for a dissident overseas like
him is not to be a compromiser or a
diplomatist but people always accusing
them not being diplomatic but he's not a
diplomat he's not an elected party
official he's a dissident and the whole
point of it of a dissident and all you
can expect of them you can't expect them
to suddenly have a huge impact on
politics in China but you what you do
should expect from that they stick to
their principles that when people say
the Chinese don't want democracy or
don't know what freedom is or something
like that there's that man who was
prepared to spend more than a decade in
jail for that principle and as such he
is valuable and you never know I mean
when things start to change in China
such people can suddenly play a role
that now we can't imagine so I think to
simply denounce their personal frailties
is a lot of people have done is to do
them a disservice and it's to miss the
point just sort of on that now as you
can see don't expect to have a huge
impact on democracy in China is there
any way that they could sort of improve
the limited effect that they could have
along the lines began a more effective
group like a human rights in China that
has had a very positive impact and has
done a lot of force worthwhile research
and advocacy yes obviously in that sense
but that's more what they can do in
America more than what they can do in
China the other thing is that voices
aren't complete
the crushed either I mean because of the
internet and radio free asia and so on
and so forth i mean their opinions do
get through in china but i think that
the main thing they can do effectively
indeed is to keep people focused in the
west on the problems of china and and
and because governments are all too much
inclined to to turn a blind eye
especially now and china is a valued
Ally in coalition and there's a lot of
business to be done some of us are
working on early China and we're trying
to look beyond the Confucian veil and
we're seeing encouraging signs of rule
of law roots and other
anti-authoritarian trends and I wonder
if you think these can be drawn upon or
if people in in China and outside the
boundaries can use some of these
traditions to rebuild a legal society
for example that might point toward
democracy or do you see this
authoritarianism is so deeply entrenched
that there's no way out of it well
people often talk about rule of starting
with the rule of law and then perhaps it
can evolve to a more democratic
political system but it's certainly the
rule of law can be improved and is being
improved I mean more people are now
accountable in cases of corruption and
so on particularly when there are
political interests involved we're even
more powerful people want to purge those
who've committed those acts of
corruption but certainly law it's there
is a lot of room for improvement which
could happen without a political
transformation but I think it's highly
limited because as long as the
government or the party is itself not
accountable to to the law it's very
difficult to see how you can really
speak of the rule of law because in the
end it's the party that decides and and
and they're not accountable according to
the law of the land and I think that can
only happen with the political
transformation but you nonetheless I
mean one person I described in the book
is a lawyer and shinji
who takes care of industrial cases of
industrial accidents and he's one of not
the only one and these are people who
have a deep understanding of the
importance of the law and are trying to
apply it and so on but without real
political change I think it's always
going to be there's going to be a glass
ceiling well not even a glass ceiling a
steel ceiling to this if I could follow
up I think part of the thrust of Karen's
question is that less to do with the
party but more as a China does in time
generally democratize are there
resources in the Chinese past that one
draws on to make a genuine democracy
with x characteristic not not not a
false or excuse what if you comment on
that giving your own rich but I think
there's a political philosophical
problem that has to be dealt with first
and I and this is something I think that
is true of Taiwan and it's still true of
Japan to some extent which is that the
traditional use of the law in East Asian
societies was very much as a tool for
those who ruled to control control the
citizens and not as a tool for the
citizens to protect their rights against
the power of the state and there are
many Chinese intellectuals lawyers and
so on who do grasp that fact and I think
it's certainly true that I would turn
your question perhaps the other way
around i think that there's perhaps I
mean at the risk of cultural arrogance
but there is perhaps more hope for
people who pick up that kind of concept
of the rule of law from studying abroad
and so on and bringing it back then to
look for
Chinese traditions in which I mean the
form can be traditional and it can be
adapted and so on but i think that
fundamental question has to be has to be
resolved for see a democratic uprising
at any time in the future the
foreseeable future to use for see twice
and if so would such a enterprising have
a chance of success i don't see in the
near future another ten on moon and
precisely for the reasons that i was
trying to address just now that i think
for the time being the party might very
well get away with making it worth
enough worth the while of the students
the urban he leads the educated people
to stick to the status quo because you
can have a good life you can make money
you can live in comfort and so on why
rock the boat so the kind of people who
hit the streets in 1989 might now be
much less inclined to do so on the
contrary the the theory that's been
around and still around that business is
good because business produces a middle
class and the middle class produces
democracy i think is is fallacious it
can happen that way but in as the
singaporean at all the east asian
countries in general show it can also go
to another direction it can produce an
extremely conservative middle class that
doesn't want to rock the status quo and
if they don't give leadership the won't
be quote unquote a democratic rebellion
you might be other kinds of rebellions
which would be more or less violent but
i don't see another town then i can
imagine more and more violence in Rust
Belt cities in the countryside what do
the Tibetans and Mongolians and rigorous
you know say about desperations and what
do you think is the best way to solve
the issue
well I have don't really have a clear
answer on the best way to solve this
issue well I have a nice pose an ideal
way to solve the issue but that's not to
say that that's very likely to happen
and I know less about the Uighurs
situation than I do about the Tibetan
situation and Tibet seems to me a pretty
straightforward case of colonialism with
one difference from European and
American colonialism of the past which
is that the Europeans ran their Asian
colonies usually with tiny minorities
Western minorities and they did it by
using the local elite and by basically
creating an atmosphere which made it
unimaginable for the colonial people to
rebel against their Western rulers now
in the case of Tibet and west western
China this is something different and
more sinister going on which is that the
the Chinese are flooding the mid the
cities with Han Chinese so that Tibetan
cities very quickly if not already we'll
end up with a majority hun population
and then the Tibetans on the one hand
and the Muslims in western China and the
other will become either remain nomadic
or become sort of village people for
whom it's very who basically cut off
from the economic reforms that are going
on and it will make it very difficult
for them to really change the situation
indeed in tibet i think that the there
are Tibetans who in the the classic
colonial way play a big part in the in
the in the in the government of Tibet I
mean there's some of them become civil
servants very few of them have a part
play a big part in the economy which is
largely Han Chinese and what would be an
ideal solution I suppose an ideal
solution would be some kind of
Federation of democratic states where
Taiwan and Tibet and so on could all
have their place but to say that this is
likely would be I think over-optimistic
um this is kind of a change in direction
but mr. Broome have always enjoyed your
articles on film and popular culture and
I thought was very interesting that you
mentioned earlier about talking to
Taiwanese activists who had what you
call japanee filia and this is certainly
true but could be understandable within
the context of their particular colonial
legacy what I find interesting is the
contemporary Chaplin Ophelia in Asia and
I was wondering if you could comment on
that especially among Taiwan youth yes
not just Taiwan youth also in China and
in Southeast Asia if you look at
television gameshows pop music and so on
it's Japan has become perhaps an even
greater influence now than the United
States and in that sense Japan is I
suppose playing a role that it's played
since the late 19th century which is
that it's the sort of the the conduit of
Western fashion into other parts of East
Asia and and it's made more palatable I
mean they've sorted the Japanese are
very good at sort of at Asian izing
Western fashions so you get American pop
and television shows and so on they come
to and the Japanese Japanese it and and
that Japanese version is more is closer
to the hearts of many people in Thailand
and in Hong Kong and Taiwan and so on
and I suppose in literature the success
of somebody like Murakami haruki is an
example of this I mean he got a lot of
his inspiration from Raymond Chandler
and an American literature but has
injected a kind of contemporary Japanese
spirit into it which is very close to
the hearts of many people in the rest of
eustacia and so when people talk about
too glibly about Americanization i think
they forget that there are many
variations of pop culture that take
place all over the world I wanted to say
one thing about whether they're there
are legal traditions which can be useful
in modernizing law in China which are
the needs of this kind of use of law to
control the populace because there are
some which are
less publicize less written about on the
local level like forms of contract and
also before the Imperial period there's
you know much more common law style as
sorts of law that's one thing I'd like
to say which I think can be useful in
coming to a modern legal system but
thinking about ways in which the outside
world can influence China in favorable
and unfavorable ways I remember when the
mangy Constitution was being shopped
around Europe all the great legal
scholars airing homes everybody said
this is fine because Japanese people
can't take more democracy than this if
you look at that Constitution is very
undemocratic I see business saying the
same thing about China now they say oh
the Chinese you know they have a very
calm bc down looking patronizing
attitude towards the chinese people they
can't take democracy they're not going
to Dale fall apart into a pile of sand
so you know I think the people outside
China have to keep the faith with
Democratic traditions and with the
Chinese people that know I couldn't
agree more and and also West it's not
just businessmen and Western experts
have often played a negative role in
this too in that when the Meiji resident
the Meiji constitution was rewritten
under the under MacArthur and the
American occupation it was often
American experts who quote unquote new
the Japanese mind who agreed with the
most reactionary Japanese opinions on
that there would be disorder and so on
if they had a more democratic
institution it was often as far as
Japanese tradition is concerned relative
ignoramuses who came over from the
United States and when new dealers and
so on who found common cause with
Japanese liberals and indeed public
opinion in Japan so I think to use these
to look at culture and tradition to
solve legal and political problems is a
very problematic thing and I and I agree
with you that it can sometimes work if
only to take if only to criticize the
wrong use of it when people indeed I
mean when people say well but the
Confucian tradition means that people
are naturally
bedient to the to the authorities well
it's helpful to point out that
Confucians himself actually said in man
she's even more that the scholar
gentleman had the right to criticize his
ruler and he thought the ruler was
making mistakes absolutely and but this
is not something that this is not part
of li konn use concept of chinese
tradition mr. Bruma i'd like to ask you
a hypothetical question based on your
acquaintance with all different kinds of
Chinese dissidents and reformers if you
were a Chinese reformer what sort of
reform which you be would you try to
work from within the Communist Party
would you try to be marginal but
legitimate like someone might die Ching
would you would you join a democracy
party and put in and get put in jail
would you go abroad how would you go
about it yourself I suppose because I'm
a coward I'd probably go abroad but if
you were to be really shrewd I suppose
you would try and you become leader of
the Communist Party and do a Gorbachev
and keep quiet about it but that's not
going to happen because Gorbachev in
many ways did China a great disservice
because he precisely did that I mean he
thought he was going to save the
Communist Party by introducing
democratic reforms and look what
happened and the Chinese did look and
they know what happens so that kind of
reform is very unlikely to happen inside
the party I mean the problem I think is
that one can talk about reforms and
incremental reforms and things getting
slowly better and the growth of civil
society and so on and so forth but until
the party is forced in one way or
another to give up its monopoly there
won't be a fundamental change and I
don't see the party doing that
voluntarily or any leader anybody who
becomes leader of the party doing a
voluntary also you don't get Gorbachev's
who become leader of the Chinese
Communist Party now they tend to be much
more like leaders of the LDP in Japan I
mean party hacks who backroom dealers
and don't make enemies and mediocrities
on the whole but but shrewd party
machine operators these people are not
going to be bold reformers
do you feel confident that should the
Communist Party give up its monopoly on
power that the alternative or its
successor will necessarily be an
improvement I mean let me suggest two
things to think about one is organized
crime in the former Soviet Union another
is Falun Gong I recall that the the
occasion the direct occasion for the
large demonstration that got Falun Gong
band was fallen gongs demands that
criticism of Falun Gong in the Shandong
press BB not permitted yes I don't see
the Falun Gong as a democratic
organization but then there's there's
absolutely no danger that that they are
going to take over the government I
agree also that if if if a traditional
pattern were to be repeated and a change
of government where to take place at the
result of some violent millenarian
movement it would be almost undoubtedly
worse the only thing that would be
better would be something along the
lines of Taiwan or South Korea or Japan
or Thailand which would be a halting and
messy but nonetheless more democratic
system and to assume that the Chinese
can't handle that is to do the Chinese
people a great disservice because if the
Koreans can do it and the Japanese and
the ties why not the Chinese I mean to
assume that is to think that the
something that indeed that there is sort
of poison in Han Chinese blood which is
not my assumption is China just too big
well to that there's a one-word answer
which is India and the Indian democracy
is not flawless and there are many
problems there and about we all know but
it has held its ass it is a system where
the rascals have been voted out when it
was necessary and I think the
alternative in India would be far far
worse it would could very easily become
a huge Kashmir if they didn't have
legitimate ways to fight out their
conflict and so I don't think the size
of a country is especially germain I
mean it's often said
will taiwan succeeded because it's a
little island well what about North
Korea which is even smaller so I mean
the dictatorship works very well in
small countries just as much as
democracy can and I don't think this the
size is the point it may be true that
that large and diverse countries need a
different system from the the one that
they have in let's say the Netherlands
but therefore I think some kind of
Federation is probably a plausible
answer but to say just because China is
so big it can't handle democracy I
wouldn't say I think quite the contrary
I think because it's so big it's very
different for difficult for a central
government to control it and you need a
lot of autonomy for different regions
and so on hi mr. Broome I've watched
your career and seen how been impressed
by how you've been are able to write
perceptively about really a diverse
array of topics and I remember the last
time I encountered you in person you
were the keynote speaker at a conference
we organized about the rape of Nanjing
it at Princeton turbulent okay yeah very
memorable and I question is more about
your career as a writer how you choose
what you write about how you've chosen
to be a writer rather than an academic
and also what what you see is your role
but I don't know about my role but I
think what the courier one chooses
unless your child prodigy which I wasn't
who spends the whole day what thinking
of nothing but playing the piano or
writing short stories or whatever a lot
of it is accident and I was in in Japan
thinking I was going to be a
photographer and a filmmaker and then I
started writing film reviews and
realized that expressing my opinion and
in prose actually was more congenial to
me than taking photographs and one thing
then leads to another as far as what one
writes about I think probably every
writer has
a limited number of main themes which
probably basically autobiographical and
I've always been very interested in how
people define themselves in their
communities in the case of and
culturally and nationally and that I
suppose is the result of having grown up
with parents from different countries
and speaking two languages as when I was
a child and my family background is
complicated by other factors but I mean
there are many different cultures in it
and so you grow up with in a way that
that you can never take a cultural
behavior for granted there's always
another I which is looking at edit from
a dislike Lee different perspective and
that's made me interested I suppose in
how people in in Asia since I spent a
lot of time there look at themselves and
what it means to Chinese when they said
what to be Chinese or Japanese to be
Japanese and it's those things that I've
always been very interested not only in
Asia but I mean I wrote a book about how
why Europeans either love or hate
England and it's all about those kind of
perceptions I suppose I have another
question mr. Bruno I wonder okay I want
to know the gap why the Chinese oversees
all the other Chinese Democrats fighters
in China have somewhat still fail in
fact favorite incense not only in the
compliment but but also in really
people's lack of awareness and the lack
of attention in such kind of things my
personal opinion is people have become
elite those those democracy democracy
fighters have become elite and they
really i mean in comparison to four
examples 50 or 70 years ago the Chinese
comes party they really work with
agricultural workers and all that so I
wonder what's your comments yes but but
I wouldn't say the
that's because of some moral failing of
the elite I think it's people react to
the circumstances there in when people
for example when people say oh well
young educated Chinese are really only
interested in money or career people
often say the they forget that people
said that about Chinese students in 1988
and these things can change so quickly
if the same people who would now claim
which they do many yuppies in Beijing do
but everything is fine you know change
is slowly coming we're having a good
life who are these foreigners to tell us
what to think and so on quite
nationalistic often those same people
you know who it given a different set of
circumstances if the were the chance to
have another Tiananmen tomorrow the same
people probably would go to the square
and suddenly become very politically
active think of the reporters for the
people's daily who marched through the
streets in nineteen eighty nine days
after they were writing propaganda often
and so these things can change awfully
quickly and i don't think that are some
kind of deep moral failing in in the
chinese elite or anything like that i do
think and as i said earlier that the
Chinese Communist Party is very
deliberately trying to make that elite
think of nothing but material
development in its own interests and so
on and therefore not tension to people
in the rural areas and I think you're
right and I think that's dangerous you
think there is a strategic filler of
food Democracy fighters I mean I mean
what would not really because I don't
see what what else they could cognition
though that well but soon people have
tried this in the 1980s people did try
and set up independent organizations at
universities and think tanks and so on
this of course was crushed after 1989
and any attempt made by people to start
an organization for example the
Democratic Party you end up in jail so
it's it's made it's very very difficult
to do
to think of it to have a strategic way
of pushing for democracy in China and I
wouldn't fall toward announced anybody
for a lack of courage or anything like
that because I think it's real it's
genuinely very difficult thank you for a
wonderful talk so far my question has
more to do with what does if you know
what the Chinese government thinks of
your work and given that you do have to
enter and work there how does the
looming presence of that government
influence your work well they haven't
influenced me and nor have I ever
noticed that they try to hinder me or
put any very on my way but then I've
never really done anything especially
clandestine or illegal I mean I've never
done anything to break the law in China
I just go around and listen to what
people have to say and what they think
now and I really have no idea i'm sure
that Jung soo min if he in the very
unlikely event that he would ever read
my book would not particularly like it
but I'm not anti-chinese although i'm
sure i will be branded as such by some
and i would like like most chinese i
would like the Chinese to be free like
us and so I can't think too much about
what the government thinks of me who
knows as you said no people's daily
journalist deriding propaganda next day
these did too much what triggers them
and what triggers them opportunity
because when people everybody has to
make a living and if you're intelligent
and you work for the people's daily you
know that much of what you write is
nonsense but at the moment you're
allowed to say say that it is nonsense
and claim that you actually want to tell
the truth you'll do so so it's a I don't
think there's a deep mystery there
of course I have many questions I would
like to ask let me live my self 202 now
you even Havel very nicely in the book
and much of what you said today strikes
me as reminiscent of him I wonder have
you engaged hop over sent him this book
or others to garner his reflections on
these sources but the book was sent to
him and I did I I never engaged I've met
it shook his hand once but now I've
never had a conversation with him but I
not the it it's not original of me to
bring up Harvell in the jacket in the
Chinese context because many Chinese
intellectuals again especially in the
80s read half or Sidious Lee and quoted
him often and one thing that is I think
a lot of Westerners still have an idea
of China as a sort of closed society and
this certainly isn't true and there's an
awful lot of information available in
China and partly through the internet
but also in bookstores and the take our
own the post colonial discourse
academics who like to present themselves
as being tremendously marginal
marginalized figures you go into a
Beijing bookstore and there's Edward
side and Fredric Jameson and piled up so
it's it's it's a wide open society in
that sense your hover mouse gave
lectures at jing hua so you're indeed
correct actually won the follow-up
question that talks to go to the openers
what do you envision the implications
for chinese society will be of the WTO
accession well i think in in the short
term at least it's going to benefit the
d educated elite those who know how to
operate in a global economy but it will
clearly create a lot of tensions because
it's going to mean a lot of people
getting laid off put pressure on
agriculture and so on and the Chinese
this is no secret i mean the chinese
leaders clearly are worried about it in
Jerome G is is is openly worried about
it but they've gambled that somehow they
can hand
all that and hope that the the affluence
will trickle down enough in time that
they can defuse the situation but it is
a it is a gamble and they're not they
don't hide that take a few more but you
you put it to India as an example of a
populous country I guess about to pass
China which has a parliamentary
democracy but would you dispute an
assertion that in some aspects of life
and society but that the life in China
is freer than life in India I'm thinking
in particular of issues of caste and
gender yes but i think that would depend
a lot on class i think if you're if
you're a middle class relatively
well-off middle-class person in in delhi
or Bombay you're no worse off and
probably better off in many ways than
your equivalent in China it's certainly
true than in rural areas to be a
low-cost woman for example is probably a
worse fate then is suffered by most
Chinese women in rural areas and on the
other hand don't underestimate the
suffering of Chinese in in backward
parts of the country but nonetheless yes
I think that's true but what do we
conclude from that not that democracy
somehow is not a better alternative to
what they have that freedom is a large
concept and parliamentary democracy is
is a very is an aspect of it yes indeed
not coextensive with it absolutely one
more question and then wrap up our
session I won't continue to follow up we
offered question about the WTO and that
I okay there there are some kind of
left-wing the comments about that and I
met one American in Beijing he said
basically China today is not under the
control for a kind of a communist party
okay it's certainly no everybody knows
he's no longer a communist party but he
just said it's a under a in fact a
catalyst a big capitalists and in fact
those who are coming at me also WTO know
that I mean I personally invadin thats
that's a real threat in fact and I
wonder how much I mean it's it's really
under a threat of a forthcoming
imperialists oh I don't know what about
this kind of threat oh is it more a
threat of really a some other kinds I
mean lack of me I'm or author entire
empower I yeah well I think the threat
is that the party has itself become more
and more capitalist in other words and
that if you have economic reforms in a
capitalist direction without political
reforms then you can get a very harsh
society where the Communists were the
party whether they call them communists
or anything else becomes like a kind of
mafia where political power is
translated into economic power and that
would lead to another kind of
authoritarianism and I think the WTO and
and once i mean i agree with with some
of the left-wing critiques of this but i
don't think that that bringing back
state socialism is the answer i mean the
debate and china of course as you know
is not between the Democrats and the
autocrats at the moment it's between the
communist capitalists if you like and
the real leftists whose magazines are
also now being banned and closed down
because the real left is so now they
have now become the main dissidents
thank you thank you very much